what ups face fam goes in here from
anime uproar back at it again to discuss
the latest developments in the one piece
story and let me just say it's good to
be back with Luffy and the straw hats if
you enjoyed these one piece reviews and
want to keep them coming the best thing
you can do is smash that like button and
share this video with a friend if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and this is
crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future one piece videos when they
drop and while you wait for the new
videos you can check out our playlist of
one piece videos including videos about
the Yann CO and warlords keep in mind
there will be manga spoilers we're
talking about the latest chapter chapter
975 after all now without further ado
let's get back to the worst generation
trio as they were heading to fight Kaito
and by extension Big Momma the hype
level is indeed off the charts
chapter 975 is called King emmalin's
plan we start to chat there with Shinobu
being in danger remember she was left
with momonosuke and so when we saw
kanjuro using him as a hostage we knew
something must have happened to Shinobu
we just didn't know exactly what but now
we know how she's being kept from
helping monoski snakes likely drawn by
conjured oh are wrapped around her
perhaps ready to give her some fatal
poisonous bites as we know now control
the betrayer is not the crappy artist
that he led us to believe he was he's
actually incredibly talented at drawing
and he can even make an exact copy of a
human let alone of an animal still
though despite his treachery things are
not going according to chondros plan
Luffy kit and law who were imprisoned
are out and ready to fight we then see
some of the other straw hats which adds
even more to the height the straw hats
were mostly off-screen last chapter but
here we see Frankie laughing at the idea
that bombs could destroy the Sonny he
even calls the enemy's q2 being
patronizing he remarks that the ship is
made using wood from the atom tree the
same incredibly strong material used for
gol D Roger ship a ship that
successfully sailed to the end of the
Grand Line I love watching the pride
Frankie takes in his work and since I've
been rereading one piece from the start
I can really appreciate how important
such a good carpenter is to have on a
ship that's something I really love
about one piece how it's not like
everyone's goals the same in Luffy is
the
best know all of these guys are masters
in their own domain and want to be the
best at different things in that sense
they complement each other and can help
each other move close to their
individual goals although I love
Dragonball Z it's clear that in
Dragonball pretty much everyone starts
out wanting to be the strongest until
they get left behind in the dust you
don't see Crillon wanting to be a master
carpenter or swordsman that's one of the
big strengths of one piece in my opinion
everyone's dreams are intact as they
move forward together anyways the reason
our boys are a little late is that the
sales took some time to repair can't
blame Frankie for that we see Rockstar
Brook Robin and the ever cute carrot
Chon Luffy looks epic AF with the coat
over his shoulders I must say I am
digging that aesthetic our people
expected more allies Baloo fee is not
too bothered he's pretty confident in
getting past these bees ships which is
funny in and of itself because of how
freakin huge they are it's like an early
dragon ball when tiny Goku used to take
on huge opponents and crush them except
here it's on a larger scale with ships
we see Sanji our favorite reindeer
chopper and my favorite line musketeer
Sicilian we see Zorro and Nami too who
still has big mom Zeus with her an
amazing addition to the team which makes
Nami way more powerful so I really hope
she can keep him for as long as possible
he looks great in his samurai hat too we
see the other two in watashi Musketeers
as well
you gotta love Oda and all of his
references on one piece to history and
great works of literature if you haven't
check out the three musketeers by
Alexandre Dumas thank me later it's
great to see her group back but they're
wondering where is everyone where the
prisoners other musketeer members
weapons and so on kena Moana apologizes
to them saying all of their strategies
and plants have been found out he has no
idea what happened to everyone the
beasts pirates with some funky character
designs of their own say that they
destroyed the ships and the major
bridges but they don't mention killing
any forces kena moon is clearly
distressed they need boats to get to
onigashima and this Knight appears to be
their last chance then we get some crazy
AF info the funny bird pirate says that
today will be a banquet in honor of the
alliance between the
you'd be screw and the big mob crew
meaning that they can expect the most
concentrated force of both crews to be
there some of you asked if our boys knew
about this alliance and it seems clear
now that they didn't Captain Kidd is
surprised as is law calling it an
emperor's alliance the Beast pirates set
up a narrative of Luffy law and Kidd
being completely irrelevant
they say nothing will change because
three little pirate ships try to help
the samurai they even point out that
they've already been defeated in one or
once which is fair enough
the Beast pirates really act like
sinking these three small pirate ships
will be easy
I love seeing Luffy law and kid all
fight over which one is going to wreck
the enemies we're so certain of their
superiority and victory although caught
off guard it looks like none of our
pirate captains are gonna change their
plans because another freaking yong-chol
and her powerful crew joined they're
already beyond opie enemies I also love
how Luffy wasn't even shown being
surprised when the big bomb Alliance was
announced he says unfazed as usual just
wanting to rush into battle as soon as
possible like a true pirate king I must
say this must be one of the most epic
trios of all time they're all captains
all fighting over glory trying to be the
top dog we see them all use signature
moves like Kidd with Punk rotten Luffy
with bow man and law with room the beast
pirates are practically wetting
themselves by this point the huge ship
in the center gets destroyed showing
that in Shonen size really doesn't
matter these three pirates from their
relatively small boats completely
overpowered this larger vessel like it
was nothing the fighting has definitely
started then Colonel comes into the mix
and we know he's actually danger but no
one else does the enemies think danger
is here to save them but then danger
goes on to attack their ship he attacks
the Beast pirate ship to the surprise of
the men onboard who look at yo [ __ ] off
like a boss but he doesn't hurt them he
just neutralizes their cannons with his
sword like a true Opie swordsman his
owner recognizes Khursheed or some
swords with the sword and respect right
there and he's also probably trying to
figure out what's going on our guys
don't know dangerous secret after all
then Shore refers directly to the
scabbard and asks them to allow the
entire kyoshiro family all 200
members to join them for the raid
against Kaito the men who expected
Yoshino to save them are shocked and
everyone is wondering why he'd do such a
thing
why would he turn against the man he
works for Orochi then danger mentions a
mound god incident where Odin saved
keenum on his future wife to rue d'Anjou
dough and everyone else from the giant
war and even took all the blame on
himself
after this incident both kena moon and
dan judo had the biggest man crush on
Odin and you can't even blame that Odin
was very cool back in the present densha
takes off his wig and tells Kenan London
it was he who caused the incident and
Kinnaman knows that dan judo is the only
other person who would know that that's
when Kenan moon puts it together and
screams out that it must be Dan judo
then Joe confirms that it is in fact him
and explains they couldn't reveal
himself sooner because he wanted to play
it safe
truly a wise move as we know now since
kanjuro turned out to be a traitor dan
judo reveals that he needed to stay in
his position so that he could release
one thousand samurai from prison now he
asked for the scabbard to allow these
1,000 Samurai and the two hundred
members of the kyoshiro family to join
them then we get a pretty hilarious part
then drew builds up Kingdom on for being
smart enough to fool kanjuro he explains
how keen Amon purposely misunderstood
Yost who's drawing to read the wrong
port when it clearly meant another port
it was obvious to everyone else but
Kinnaman told his close friends the
wrong port and so the spy passed on the
wrong facts to Orochi kanjuro is shocked
his facial expression is gold he
inadvertently helped trick Orochi so the
actual forces are fine
everyone had passed the bridges before
they were destroyed and the ships were
already gone all the ships that were
destroyed which were mentioned earlier
were just extra long story short all
4,200 fighters who we thought were gone
are actually safe and sound and ready to
fight how freakin quickly things change
imagine how hopeless Kenan one and the
rest must have felt just last chapter
they knew there was a traitor among
their already small number
weather conditions were terrible and
they were in the worst tiny boat
possible a boat that had
no place being on the water in a storm
things look bleak and hopeless and wow
what a turnaround has happened here it
goes to show how quickly things can
change
now they got Luffy's crew lost crew and
kids crew the 4,200 fighters plus then
general and the 1200 men he's bringing
into the mix they have more men than
they could have ever expected I
absolutely love it and it goes to show
how suddenly things can change even when
they look their bleakest now we even got
our elder Yakuza boss she'll go to a
present and ready to kick some Beast
pirate but the raid is taking place and
now the forces are closer to 5400 people
then drew is serious and cool saying
onigashima here we come
Luffy in his abdomen it way is just
enjoying the view and even though he
does understand how it worked out he's
glad that everything went well and that
the forces are alright no need to
question it it worked out and he's ready
to kick some butts the enemies are
freaking out sweating and crying danger
compliments Keenan moan one more time
emphasizing how much respect he deserves
for pulling all this off kanjuro is
furious and curses Keenan moon for
tricking him meanwhile Keenan moon is
like yes of course even though he had no
idea he got the port wrong he plays it
off cool like of course he knew but he
actually made a mistake that ended up
saving everyone it's classic oda
combining epic hype with humor and
managing to pull them both off that's
the beauty of one piece it can be cooler
than James Bond and funnier than the
office at the same time we are told that
luck is our team's side at the end of
this chapter and it definitely is
since Keenan moon stumbled into an
amazing situation by accident but he's
gonna take full advantage of that I feel
like they're probably so many cases in
history where things like this had
happened where things just work out
expectedly and some guy is just like yes
I planned it all along but on a serious
note as the saying goes fortune favors
the brave Kinnaman was brave when all
hope seemed lost he took a shot and he
was rewarded he totally deserved this
accidental victory we're told that there
will be no chapter next week well we
will have color pages to look forward to
right now things seem to have been
explained
nicely and the puzzle pieces have fallen
into place denture has revealed his
identity the forces are present and
ready our pirates are all here and they
know that Kaito and big mom have an
alliance everything built up to this
point intricately and now is the time
for battle let me know on a scale of one
to ten how hype you are for this war in
the comments what do you think is gonna
happen in the next chapter and what do
you think are gonna be some of the major
highlights in this war clearly these
beasts pirate ships won't be a problem
to get past so we should be getting to
some of the bigger boss battles soon and
I can't wait
keenum on accidental MVP of this chapter
no doubt he single-handedly tricked
orochy kanjar-ro and even himself you
know people say you have to trick your
friends in order to trick your enemies
but ki naman proves that a true master
has to trick themselves to trick their
friends to trick their enemies Bravo
but anyways that is it for this chapter
review if you enjoy it and want to see
more like it the best thing you can do
is smash that like button and share this
video with a friend if you haven't be
sure to subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future one piece reviews and you
don't want that cuz things are gonna get
crazy AF real soon
a special thank you goes to our patrons
over on patreon who help us survive
YouTube issues and who helped make
videos like this one possible first and
foremost I want to thank our the one to
your patrons the ones who stay atop all
clans Steven and Greta
hello Lana attempt the world stealers
the school bus Theisen Kirino acquire
respect potato feh and Chris Loki and I
can't forget our pro hero tier patrons
the one and only Gilgamesh nothing but a
fan Jason Wilson Odin Anatole Kazansky
alpha do angel Cruz team Sparky 65 Rohan
Kapoor Creek and XP $50.00 beat Ted no
Ted Joel - Joel Stanton very gucci
jessica calif on alicia actor emperor
otaku and JC c walk up thank you all so
much if you enjoy our work you can
support more of it by going over to
patreon.com slash anime uproar and
becoming a patron today for as little as
one dollar if you do so you'll get your
name featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll even get access to a private
patron only discord where we talk about
anime life and of course dank memes so
check out patreon community or
interested you can also now join the
youtube channel and support more content
that way if you prefer
whichever way you choose to support us
you can get the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see us
space cowboy
[Music]